aided Acosta xavius his corruption in
Mozambique is making life even more
difficult for the poor the country is
one of Africa's fastest growing
economies with billions of dollars worth
of Natural Resources but many people
here are struggling well
money stolen by politicians is returned
and used properly it will help many poor
families
we have no jobs electricity or running
water we don't know where the money is
going
is talking about a two billion dollar
debt Scandal that crashed mozambique's
economy a court in the capital of maputo
is handing down its verdict this week 19
high-profile people are implicated
including former State security
officials and the son of former
president Amanda capuza all the accused
have denied any wrongdoing
back in 2013 and 2014 state-owned
companies borrowed two billion dollars
from International Banks to buy a tuna
fishing fleet and surveillance vessels
the government failed to disclose the
borrowing to Parliament or donors
an independent audit of the debt find
the government had not done enough to
explain how the money was spent and that
roughly a quarter of the two billion
dollars was unaccounted for we still
have government officials from the
Central Bank from the minister of
economy and finances
that were not part of the trial but
somehow they have received
bribes and they were involved in the
Scandal but yet they were saved somehow
from this trial so we have mixed
messages in terms of how you know the
mozambican population receives this
trial and how just it becomes to the
mozambicans when the full extent of the
Scandal was revealed in 2016 donors cut
off support for the country triggering a
dead default and the currency collapse
prosecutors here want tough sentences
handed down and for the 19 accused to
pay back the money with interest
haramatasa Al Jazeera